Yeah, you you are getting paid for like a basic you're getting
paid for like the Wii version of steak, right? That's what it
is. >> 8 years old 8-year-old boys are getting injected
with lifealtering chemicals to change their genetic code. >> we
should have done that to you to get the
molecules out of you. and the amount of
uh inside their vagina being more than a hind mayonnaise jar
as well as them thinking, you know what I'm going to do when
I grow up? I'm going to be an only fans girl. >> Okay,
I'm back.
>> Is this like it comes in and it stays in there like
a jar? >> Hold on. Is this guy Is this guy just trying
This is the most transparent I'm going to hit every Grifter.
This is like actual satire, right? Trying to hit every Grifter
like demographic at the same time.
because I wanted to I wanted to tie in with some right-wing people
who would obviously be principled on this and stand on the free
speech. Okay, free speech is important thing and
I'm going to go from there to our buddy. Okay, Cherry, do you
see uh you see the techone tweets today? >> I think this
is unironic.
I think it's actual and unironic. I >> think it's unironic.
>> I think >> Why is he hiding behind? >> This
could be like a little bit of a joke. Maybe. Maybe. But it's
like he's said it unironically so many times and he's been like
vague posting today more and more. The truth is coming. The truth
is coming. You have no idea what you created. I I tweeted. So
we Hold on. There's an Auggie tweet about this. Okay. There's
an Auggie tweet real quick. We just throw the Auggie tweet up.
I'll maybe show the Shimu one as well. But >> can this
guy get gassed already? Dude, I my actual >> What's that
mean?
Uh he is stochastically calling for terrorism, but um
anybody who's got a gas chamber, take care of this guy. Apparently
apparently that's Auggie's opinion, not mine. Okay, Auggie's
crazy. But I am now starting to think in my head. I'm like, dude,
we might live in a world where where TeeOne becomes anti-semitically
conspiracized. Okay. He he he's convinced of anti-semitic conspiracies
after Israel loses its grip on like American government and and
American like thought. Like after they they get rid of all the
anti-semitism laws, all of the BDS laws. Okay. After they get
rid of all of it, then Teone's going to fall down the anti-mitic
rabbit hole. Can he fall down first and then run a foul of those
laws? Could we please, please, Teone, don't take too long. Hit
your Lucas Gage arc.
Please, Teone. I want him to hit his Lucas Gage arc. Okay, please.
I need you to do it. Is it funny or if Teone already had this
phone in his phone or this photo in his phone or if he took the
photo for this tweet? I think he took this photo. They thought
it was funny and then he decided to tweet this out. Hold on a
second here. Check this out. I got this from uh We got this thrown
in the Discord. I don't know what this is supposed to be. This
is terrifying. Okay. What is this? What is this? What is this?
>> He looks like um the thing from
the Adams family. What is it? Uncle Fester? He could be an Uncle
Veester. >> Like an Uncle Fester looking ax. >> He's
a He's a bit of a goof. Okay.
Now, Techton also dropped a video today. This is the thumbnail
for the video, in fact. Okay. This is a thumbnail for the video.
I have I gotten Why are you guys keep linking mouse tweet? Like
my eight written pages. Oh, I see.
He's like a quest giver. I get it a little bit.
I get it. But also, wait, what? Wait, this is Wait, how did Moral
How did morale get such a massive tweet off of this? What? It's
a Slender Man reference. Oh, okay. Jesus.
1.2 million views. Moral had a banger tweet. What the [__]
I've never played the Slender Man game. He's Slender Man. He's
not Slender Man, though. He's like not Slender Man at all. Bisa
retweeted him. Oh,
let's go. Moral popping off. Damn,
Fender Man. Bro, I've never
That's wild. >> Morow, don't [__] this up by
DMing her. >> I repost. I just repost. I see. I see morale
tweet. I see morale banger. I just retweet without question.
Okay, now that we have morale here. Okay, somebody just sent
me this on Discord. Why did I get sent this? Oh, this is Can
somebody correct me if I'm wrong here? Is this Starbased? This
guy. Is this Starbased? Says I weighs in on morow drama or something.
hear about.
>> I think this is just AI.
I think this is Starbase posting some AI thing about me and morale.
>> Heads up, this stream will talk about >> Oh, this
is not even remotely good AI. Somebody messaged me and asked
if this was real. Who is enough to look at this and go, "Hey,
man, is this real?" >> Allegations involving a public figure
and a minor. >> If that's something you don't want to hear
about, feel free to step away. >> Hey man, is this real?
Hey man, is this real? audio. Hey, is this >> I'll move
on in a few minutes. All right, quick rundown so everyone's on
the same
>> uh it was sent man messaged me and said, "Wait, is this
real?" >> Hey, man. Is this just looking to confirm this
is AI, right? >> He still talks to you.
>> Uh, no, I don't think so.
>> Oh, okay.
>> Just looking to confirm this is AI, right? This is AI,
right? No, no. This is from my from a stream a few weeks ago
>> page. There are allegations that Maro, who is in his
early 20s, had flirtatious and suggestive conversations with
is weird. Maro. Maro.
Why is Starbase so spiteful? Why is this guy so spiteful? Why
is he using all of his all of his time, all of his energy to
go after like
on Twitter and YouTube and why? It's just sad. Uh, why not? >> I
need to cover the star-based allegations in full. I'm aware of
the star-based allegations,
but I don't care. It's such a waste of time, dude. What a waste.
Complete waste of time. Okay, we'll do the Shimu tweet and then
we'll jump into the techone video. Okay. And >> radical
techie versus techie. Hello. I can feel myself becoming radicalized.
You have no idea what you've created,
dude. There's no way the same guy did both of these statements.
There's no way. and to imply that I'm the zoom. >> I don't
know what to do with that. >> That's so disgusting.
>> After I myself have been raped twice and to imply that
I'm a >> to watch it again. >> After I myself have
been raped twice. >> No, that's like he sounds like a dog
who just came inside after running outside all day. This man
was raped. We
that now here's the thing.
Yes, he was raped in the past, but the the actual painful moment
here is that he was raped, you know, mentally, spiritually
by Hassan [__] Okay, that's that's the real in the
situation. It's Hassan obviously.
Um, it was brutal. It was brutal. after I
I'm so anyway
after these after this amazing moment okay after these tweets
or before possibly he released a new video just called failure
it's simply called failure
>> the new the new techie video okay new techie video techone
one of our favorites all right get that man a bowl of water
dude I the goatee is an interesting look all Right. >> We
need to get him with that sound effect and put him in front of
like a doggy bowl of water. It will make a lot more sense. >> Will
it? I don't know. He cries a new soundboard. Maybe. >> Maybe.
Maybe.
>> I I don't know. Like I follow Teeone and I have no idea.
He's like literally 1v100
of like the shadows in his brain and he is like he's like on
an epic quest of his own that nobody else can participate in.
It's taking place entirely in his mind. He's like left. He's
unplugged from the internet so he can go and like level up by
walking his dog occasionally and going for like walks with his
girlfriend. And he's like, "This is, guys, you have no idea how
how amazing this is. I figured out how to be happy. It involves
like not being on Twitter 12 hours a day." It's like, "Brother,
literally everyone knew that. He just comes on to his to his
YouTube channel now and tells you things that every single person
who's over the age of like 14 could tell you just from any amount
of experience dealing with the world. And he say he says all
of these things as if it's like true incredibly like profound
knowledge about the world. >> Yeah, he's spreading wisdom.
>> Yes, he's like spreading wisdom and he speaks as if
he's spreading wisdom
every time. It's baffling. or anybody leaves a comment. Yes,
I'm going to regrow out my beard. I was I don't know what happened.
I was going to come up with a crazy ass excuse. In reality, I
was just having one of those things where it's like I was looking
for my little razor head and I couldn't find it. So, I said,
"Oh, maybe I can free it and maybe I can just clean it up and
I everything up." And then I had to make it all lined up. But
anyways, now I end up looking like a uh extra from The Walking
Dead who's like probably got a drug
beards recently. >> Wait, who else did this? >> When
Pisco had that caterpillar on top of his >> Oh.
Anyways, I'm out here with my dog. You might see him in the background.
His name's Mango. Hopefully, you'll say hi. I just had kind of
a a moment where I kind of realized why why is all this craziness
happening in in terms of what's going on in real life on Twitter
and and what's kind of been going on with the journey uh with
me as well as what might be going wrong in your relationship.
Yeah, we're talking about a lot of topics here today. This >> this
is the guy I want to tell me how to have a relationship. the
guy whose previous two partners before whichever one he's got
now have both accused him of some form of sexual assault and
one of which one of which is actually actively pressing charges
against him. This is the guy. That's exactly who I want relationship
advice from. Let's go. The guy who the guy Okay, let's be honest.
All right, hold on. Where's the Where's the clip? Where's the
clip? Where is it? >> Dude, I am the conflict resolution
god. >> There's the clip.
Wait, did that play for you? Yes. We want we want all of all
of the relationship advice from the conflict resolution god himself.
Okay, >> this will hopefully be eyeopening
to a lot of you guys. And what I kind of want to do today is
talk about what's wrong with your relationship first and then
after that I want to go into what's wrong with what has happened
with the history of my career into what is wrong with the world
today. >> Wow. At least I think maybe maybe he's okay.
Maybe he could possibly tell me about the history of his career,
but my my relationship, anyone's relationship, and then the what's
wrong with the world
How How do those logically progress?
Who the [__] is tuning into this? Ask Noah Tannon
bomb. People making fun of this guy. People laughing at this
guy. People pointing out this guy's like a deranged schizophrenic
freak. That's who's tuning into this. Okay, this guy's like actually
to be honest I'm lying. I think there are a lot of people who
take him seriously who seriously think of him as like a person
you should look up to. I I unironically think there are a lot
of people who think he's >> Yeah. Which is even more depressing.
Okay.
Um I have to listen through what he's going to >> talk
about what's wrong with your relationship first. what's wrong
with your relationship first and that is somehow going to cascade
into >> and then after that I want to go into what's wrong
with what has happened with the history of my career.
So, the history of his career, what's gone wrong with him, and
that's going to lead to the big picture >> into what is
wrong with the world today,
>> and this is we're all we're going to hear about all
of it from TechOne. Techone's the guy who can teach us. >> And
uh just humor me a little bit. And uh once again, I'm not back
to streaming yet, but uh if you want to see me be very angry,
there goes Mango in the backyard. There's a hole back there and
he's trying to go to China, I guess. Cuz uh maybe maybe he's
worried about the state of America. I don't know. Anyways, what
is wrong with your relationship? So, you have a girlfriend?
Yeah. You with your girlfriend, right? With your girlfriend.
And you
imagine he just nails it all. Yeah. I can't really. But I don't
know why he would start here with his audience. This is the last
place he should start with his audience. Okay. You're laying
there and you know you had a long day of work and you come and
you lay on your bed and you take off your socks and you throw
them on the ground. Okay, you throw them on the ground and your
girlfriend out of nowhere
just is like, "Oh my [__] god, are you [__]
kidding me?" And you're like, "Bro, it's just a sock. Why are
you tweaking?"
It's almost like the little things you do throughout a relationship
build up over time. And some people who can't communicate, like
things go and they they reach a boiling point.
Um, wow. >> While she's yelling at you, while she's crying,
while she's worried about the future of your relationship. And
what this is an example of
is a micro versus macro issue. And in your mind, the only issue
is the socks on the floor. In her mind, it is the history of
you being a slob. Her asking you to clean up after yourself and
your absolute refusal to do it. And her worry of you being a
manchild because no matter how many times she asks you to do
these little things, you don't seem to do them. And >> Sorry,
I didn't think he was going to necessarily be wrong on these
things. I told you he was going to bring you knowledge that you
could easily understand or easily compute, easily like integrate
that everybody else understands, right? Like I I'm not a clean
person. I know that, right? I understand this. I don't when somebody
like gets mad at me for not doing like a little thing, I never
go, "Oh, it's just a little thing." Well, sorry. I might do it
sometimes. Okay. Technically, there's somebody here who could
get mad at me for this, although I don't know if you have, but
um I I understand that like there are other things going on in
those situations. Most of the time, it's not just like one little
thing that's upsetting. Everybody knows that, but he's going
to drop like incredibly obvious knowledge as if it's profound
in some way. It's not profound. Everyone knows this. >> You
know, this builds up and this builds up and this builds up. And
while you are only remembering this one instance, your girlfriend
has what I like to call pattern recognition and is worried about
the future due to what is happening now. Does that sound familiar?
>> Michael, good boy. It's a good lesson.
>> Don't look at the dog. Okay, he's got the dog so that
he's less offputting to people. Do not focus on the cute dog.
Okay, the dog is cute. Yeah, I like golden retrievers. They're
cute. Okay, do not focus on the dog. Do not let the dog blind
you to this man's to this man's like evil and the the ludicrousness
of everything he says. >> It's a very good lesson. I know
you really want to dig that hole, buddy, but we got to leave
that alone. >> Uh, Trucker Joe, I I don't think you'll
be a shooter. I take that bet, but I don't know if we'll remember.
I don't think he'd be a shooter. I think he's like going to radicalize
the next shooter is the problem. >> Oh, okay. Want to say
hi to these guys? Let me know your friends. Yeah. Have fun. Now,
let's talk about what went wrong with a lot of my career. Well,
okay. I mean, I say that yet I'm one of the most successful creators,
especially in the gotacha space of all time, though. I mean,
I'll be real. I'm I'm moving away from that pretty quick because
I'm just having a really hard time, guys, justifying playing
a game where it's going to make me spend $600 to get a new character
that's fun for 4 hours when I can go play Silk Song for 20 bucks.
You know what I mean? Like, it's just it's really hard to wrap
my head around that. It makes me feel like a to be completely
honest. I don't know. >> We're getting sponsored. >> Uh
yeah, that's probably why he confused >> What else is feeling
that? >> Also, why is this have no body hair?
This is like gross. >> Maybe some of it chestwise would
be tattoos. Maybe because he was getting tattooed he had to shave.
>> Okay, maybe
>> I don't know. I would assume. >> Anyways, let's
talk about my career. A man who's played many, many, many different
games. And with each one of these many different games, I see
an issue. It obliterates the company. It obliterates the player
base. It obliterates the fun. I leave. Move on to the next. They
get upset because I left. And then me be right about absolutely
everything. Sorry. That's just how it's been.
I worry about >> Bro, you leave a multiplayer game. Multiplayer
games fall apart pretty quickly, right? You leave a multiplayer
game, nobody's confused that the multiplayer game doesn't exist
in like 5 years. That's like every game. Yeah. you leave like
some random multiplayer game, 3, four years later the multiplayer
game is going to be taken down. It's going to be gone. Yeah,
that's like 95% of those games. Obviously, >> what I like
to call once again pattern recognition. And what I would do was
I would play these video games. I would say, "Ooh,
okay. Um,
well, they're doing a glider event where they're paying their
creators nothing. That's worrisome from a sponsorship as well
as a creator health ordeal, so we should probably talk about
that." Ooh. Okay.
So, uh, they're not going to nerf or they're not going to balance
their units. Ooh, that's very worrisome.
Okay. Oh, okay. Once again, they're releasing a bunch of these
characters. They only exist to sell on the character banner and
to promote sales for that patch. And then they're forgotten about
ever again, leaving the roster, you know, overly deep, leaving
the player base's wallet overly empty and the story,
well, episodic with no real characters keeping theme whatsoever
and them falling to the >> Who cares? >> Side in
the game story becoming forgettable at best past the first 1.0
through 1.6. >> You see what the dog does? I say this,
I'm called overly toxic. And then I go on to the next game because
the community is too stupid to understand what it is that I'm
saying, which is this isn't >> I He's basically playing
the weeb equivalent of a VLT and he's like, "Guys, I think this
game's a little exploitative. I'm going to go Yeah, you you are
getting paid for like a basic
you're getting paid for like the Wii version of Stake, right?
That's what it is. You're just playing the weeb version of stake
and you're you're doing a stake sponsorship. You're doing the
same and then you're like, "Oh, guys, I'm I'm gonna go. I don't
think they I don't think they're really in it for the players.
I think they're in it to make money." Yeah. No [__]
>> Good precedent to set. And it's not good for the future
of the game. And when I see a pattern and when I see doom, I
see it coming fast and I warn them and they don't listen. And
then I say, "Okay,
>> you see it fast." guys. Yeah. So, when in this situation
when it's Genchin Impact, he's the girlfriend, okay? And the
global passive they put on a character is the socks on the floor.
You guys get it, right? He's the girlfriend who's got what he
calls pattern recognition and he's freaking out even though it's
like a small thing. He's freaking out because he knows the pattern
that could unfold. Guys, do you get it? He's like a genius. He's
like the girlfriend. >> We'll go ahead and go to the next
game. Those games continue to meander. Every creator in the genre
continues to fall off and I will go on to the next because I
like games that are fun that treat their players well. And a
lot of these games treat you really well for the first year and
then they stop and after they stop that's when I leave. Very
simple. Now let's talk about what's wrong. I wonder if that's
just happens to coincide very very okay in a total total coincidence
total
twist of fate that probably happens to coincide with when they're
paying the most to get creators to play their games right the
first year he like shows up for the first year collects the paycheck
because he's the big streamer in the space and then he moves
on to the next game that's shocking
what a what a selfless guy he's really just helping you by making
sure he collects as many paychecks as he can >> with the
world today. What is wrong with the world today? And I'm going
to reference something fun. Communism. So, communism
makes a whole lot of sense. It does. And I really like breaking
this down for you to understand a child's mind and an adult's
mind. So, communism seems really cool, right? It does. Communism
honestly seems like the best choice that people can make for
their nation. Let's just think about this. Everybody gets everything
equally. Oh my god. Who wouldn't want to be a communist? This
is great. Everybody gets everything equally. Everybody
>> gets treated equally. And >> random anti-com rant.
Yes, that's what he's doing right now. Just a random anti-communist
rant. Okay, guys. Don't Don't Comm.
>> There's no problems whatsoever. Now, if you're a little
kid, you might be hearing that saying, "Wow, Chucky, that just
sounds really good. How do I sign up to be one of these communist?"
Well, check out us on [__] stream
>> Man, it's been a trip on Twitter, hasn't it? I I can't
believe my compilation that I made, by the way. I made that >> was
great. Yep. Hopefully I don't hear that quote in court later.
It's It's funnest thing. Elon Musk tagged Jeff Bezos over a tweet
I made at Hassan. Hassan, you have no idea the monster that you've
created in me. You really have no idea. Trust me, I am a man
who can hate for a very long time. And people have been following
my >> these guys actually show up. They show up to make
a video, make a stream, and they're like, "I can take advantage
of an outrage mob. You have no idea what you've created. I can
totally get outraged, have zero principles, and try to attack
people's jobs online. I can do that infinitely. Okay, I'm special."
No, you're literally every who flares out in like a year of doing
this. You're just Keels again. You're the same as every single
one of these people. You're like a You're like an E Miles Chong,
like a Keles, like a Taylor Loren to be honest at one iteration
in your life. Okay, you're like these people. It never lasts.
You always get made fun of and it always works out badly for
you. Yes, taking advantage of the outrage mob is not something
that lasts. It's not something that's good. And you feel powerful
when you're doing it. Yes, you do. It's going to happen to Dan.
Actually, it's going to happen to Dan Saltman.
He doesn't see it. He can't see it.
But trust us. Trust me, the rest of us do see patterns. All right.
And you you do this, you go after Oh, the quartering. Yeah. Um,
it's not a good path. It's not a good path to go down. It's never
something that lasts. It's always something where like the negative
attention you get afterwards is never worth it. But people keep
doing it. >> Channel understand that very well. I >> just
going to buy another Nissan to cope through that.
>> Maybe people don't get totally pinned down there. I
think Taylor Loren is somebody who came out of it. Um, yeah,
Taylor went back to journalism. She had like actual skills. She
she did something else. But I think with a lot of these people
it does. Oh, Brianna Woo is another one. Briana Woo is taking
advantage of an outrage mob. That is like your the ghost of your
Christmas future for Dan and Tekone and a lot of these other
people are like Keeles and Briana Woo. That's who you guys get
to be. That's your path right now. Not a good one. Not Not good.
Not fun. >> Barely wronged me. Imagine how much I'll hate
you when you are one of the biggest detractors in my life. Imagine
when you've wronged me and caused me so much unnecessary harm
over things that I've never done. Very fun. Trust me, you have
a hater for life. It's great. And no, I will never move on. Absolutely
not. I will be joining Nuaku. It's going to be great. Communism
makes a lot of sense to children. They say, "Oh, well, everybody
gets everything free. I really like that teacher. How do I be
a communist?" And then when you're an adult, you realize, well,
that does sound very good. But unfortunately corruption exists
and this can never succeed without its errors in the modern life
due to corruption and bad people. Bad people will always put
the political leaders and all of the governors and all of the
presidents and all of the figureheads above all of their citizens,
thusly uh resulting in a
>> Uh
not corruption.
Um,
I mean, different kinds of corruption.
Sure. Here, I'm going to I'm going to back this. >> Don't
you realize I'll be honest. I'm
>> I'm having a hard time staying focused on the things
he's saying about politics. He's just like a goof and it's errors
in the modern life due to corruption and bad people. Bad people
will always put the political leaders and all of the governors
and all of the presidents and all of the figureheads above all
of their citizens, thusly rel uh resulting in a dictatorship
where all the higherups have all of the money and all of the
citizens have nothing and there's no way to break out because
communism sure is fun, which is why it's really not that good
of an idea.
Now, I want to relate that. Um, I don't think this is not one
of the downsides that happens with like communism or socialism
attempts that you it requires like an authoritarian top- down
control and basically nobody is going to use that authoritarian
top- down control to actually achieve like altruistic ends and
it's almost impossible to really achieve altruistic ends when
only one person has the power or like a small group of people
has the power.
I I think that is a part of it. You guys are saying no no that's
not the only it's not the only problem. There are philosophical
problems as well, but that is like a problem in practice that
ends up like playing out >> to the
left versus the right. Now, if you Google, and go ahead, have
fun with this. You can Google this. If you Google >> I'd
say that's more like actual attempts at communism or socialism
that have happened. They end up playing out that way in my opinion.
the average age of a liberal or the average age of a libtard
or the average age of a left-leaning individual, you will find
out that they are amongst the youngest
of any type of political identifier that exists here on Earth
today. And the reason why that is is due to the fact that they
believe in this very fun fantasy.
>> I think um if we if we're picking people, okay, oh god,
should I be careful with what I'm saying? I feel like I don't
want to be careful. I want to have fun, but like I say this quite
a bit, okay? You got to politically persecute like one group
of people. Anybody who says libtard, that's got to be a class
of people that you the whole planet could just do without, right?
Like there doesn't need to anybody who says the word libtard
in 2025,
the planet would be infinitely better if those people didn't
exist anymore, right? Like I can't think of a single person I've
heard use the word libtard who's a required human for for any
human flourishing on earth whatsoever.
Not even just a required that's like a beneficial human or even
a neutral human. Every single one of these people is like not
beneficial. They're they're not just not required. They're like
actually harmful to human flourishing.
No, no, no, no. I'm not saying you got to do anything about them
latigious gamer. I'm saying that if you could just like snap
and they wouldn't exist anymore. could like write them out of
history in a peaceful way
probably.
What do you call them then? I don't know. Progressives, woke,
like there's a billion words you could use. Just libtard is like
not even accurate. It's like not useful. It's like a word. It's
It's like only the most degenerate boomers use that word. Unless
I guess you could say Tone is trying to bring it back. It's like
Tee knew what his conservative family members said in like 2014
or something and he's trying to like use that same lingo. Like
trying to pretend. He's trying to pretend that he could do it,
but he he like doesn't he hasn't been following at all. >> Land
that can never exist. They say, "Oh, we want to progress. We
want to be >> Like just do do pronouns or something, right?
Do they them, the they them. There's so many things. >> We
want everybody to be able to do whatever they want with their
bodies and their life. And while that sounds very good, unfortunately,
that leads to a Oh, hold up. Mango. [__] He's chewing
on a stick and he's chewing on an acorn. Hey, buddy. Buddy, look
at this. Look at this. Look at this puppies. You're such a good
listener. Come here. Oh, look at this baby. You're a good boy.
I know. I know. Your dad looks like a wife beater.
I know. I need to grow my beard back so I can look friendly again.
I look gay as right now, Mango. I look gay as All right. Let's
get you out of here. Okay. What is that? What is that? Holy.
All right. Let's get you out of here. Come on. Sorry about that.
I love my dog. Yeah. So, it sounds really nice. Let's let everybody
do whatever they want with their ow, dude. Bit this [__]
out of my foot. Are you crazy? Let me throw him a stick. While
that sounds very nice, let everybody do what they want with their
bodies. Uh, that leads women by the time that they're 19 years
old to have slept with 100 different men. uh their be, you know,
about as stretched out as an asthma video and the amount of uh
inside their vagina being more than a hind mayonnaise jar as
well as them thinking, you know what I'm going to do when I grow
up? I'm going to be an only fans >> Okay, I'm back. >> He
thinks
this >> it comes in and stays in there like a >> Hold
on. Is this guy Is this guy just trying This is the most transparent.
I'm going to hit every grifter. This is like actual satire, right?
Trying to hit every grifter like demographic at the same time.
Like he's trying to hit the ball. What's the next one down? He's
got like the the right-wing like anti- libtard bend. He's got
the uh the red pill thing going on now. What else is
>> I feel like did he say anything about flat earth? I
>> have bingo ready. >> No. Yeah, conspiracy is like
the next thing. It is like the next thing 100%. >> He's
got the eye. He got the eyeball tattooed on his chest now. >> Okay,
within the next 15 videos, I predict. Although, here's the thing.
He's got Nux Taku as a handler, so I don't know if he'll get
here, but I want to say within the next 10 to 15 videos, we'll
hear the words USS Liberty out of this guy's mouth. What do you
guys think? I think the the problem is I want to believe that,
but also he's got like Naku and Nuaku and Dan guiding him, so
I don't know, but I feel like it's coming. I feel like that's
the next logical step. They all take that next step. It has to
be. We have to be going there, right? I feel like we got to be
going. >> pretty sad.
>> 100 bodies at 19. I don't even He's like, brother just
watched his first Fresh and Fit episode. He fired up like Fresh
and Fresh and Fit greatest hits,
>> Yeah. I mean, another grift. I It's impossible for him
to go in every grifting direction, but if he starts taking donations
to put on the cat ears, there's an audience for that.
Dude, I don't know. This is crazy. He's like going on with the
gun tubers, too. He's like He's trying to do everything. He's
the omni grifter. He's like every grifter at once. >> Come
uh inside their vagina being more than a hind mayonnaise jar.
As well as them thinking, you know, >> is that what that
is? What you're getting at this? Women just uh women just collect
this, don't they? Women just collect every time you come inside
of a woman, they they actually collect it forever.
>> I think so. This is like the the stuff they break down
to make a kid eventually, but they if you want to make a bigger
kid, you just collect for longer. I think that's how it works.
>> No, that's not how it works. Actually, >> I think
that's how it works. I think that's how it works. >> No,
I'm not like a squirrel. I don't have pockets inside
>> where I'm just collecting semen. >> I feel like
Tech's hinting at it. And this guy seems like he's got a good
He's telling me how to fix my relationship and then he's telling
me about his career and then he's going to tell me how to fix
the world. So listen, >> you know what I'm going to do
when I grow up? I'm going to be an Only Fans girl by the time
like there's like 13year-old girls with Only Fans being their
career route. Do we all not see what the [__] wrong
with that? We got little kids saying, "hm,
you know, I played with the truck one time. Maybe that means
I'm a boy." Then we have little boys saying, "Well, I sure enjoy
playing with Barbie dolls."
Oh my god, why is my mom chopping off my
>> Like that's how that works. >> What? Why is my
mom doing Well, something bad is happening if it's your mom chopping
it off. Yeah, I don't I
that is the
He's hitting all the things like it's it's actually just um it's
like grifter schizophrenia. He's just like weaving between all
of the different like grifting points. >> It's unironically
he's got like shades and I don't even mean this as like totally
an insult. He does have like shades of Trump to him where he'll
like weave between different topics and not really connect them
well, but connect them like almost well enough that you could
see how like someone could defend it.
Like I see elements of like the the Trump thing going on with
him. I'm not joking. I can see it. Hold on. I want to pull up
this video real quick. Different timeline. Okay. Different timeline
where everything was going to be okay.
Wow. Incredible stuff.
>> Incredible stuff.
Guys,
hello. What in the are we doing when we are this tolerant to
where little children,
eight years old, 8-year-old boys are getting injected with lifealtering
chemicals to change their genetic code. >> we should have
done that to you to get
>> molecules out of you. >> But hold on. Does he
think that does he think that hormones change your genes?
>> I don't. >> That's actually not what happens.
That's actually in fact that's like the opposite of what people
think hap. Dude, this guy's
>> in a 100 different ways. No, I'm like I'm literally
just holding my head. Like this guy's in a million different
ways. Uh we actually inject that could he's like maybe he's messing
up. Okay, he that's uh that's RNA vaccines. Okay, RNA vaccines
are the ones that change your DNA. Techone, you [__]
it up. You [__] it up, buddy.
>> He's going to be the first mass shooter that does it
as a grift. >> Boys are getting injected with lifealtering
chemicals to change their genetic code.
I mean, Jesus Christ, guys. There are people who have lost their
jobs because they said there's twoing genders. There, guys. There
are people who have lost their jobs
because they said men can't give birth. >> Wait, are there
a lot of people who've lost their job? By the way, that's stupid.
That's like almost as dumb as getting fired for saying Charlie
Kirk was wrong about some things. Okay.
But like,
has that even did that even happen? There people who lost their
jobs because they went wampwamp. Yeah, exactly. Yeah, it's all
stupid. That shouldn't happen. That doesn't mean you uh at at
no point will we ever be able to stop society from just like
basing all of their opinions on the worst people who oppose them.
Like I need to check I need to find the worst person who who
thinks the opposite of what I do and then that's how I'm going
to treat everybody who believes anything even adjacent to them
is just as if they're that person. That's everyone now. Everyone
just does that. It's so lazy. It's like not humanity is like
a species is
I don't I don't know.
I don't know. If things have ever been different,
do we just did the lites have it right all along? Was all the
tech all the technology was a mistake? We just have to start
breaking the technology, right? Like Ted Ted Kazinski absolutely
absolutely clairvoyant pills. Okay, he saw the future. He knew
it was happening. We can't handle this technology. We got to
return to Monkey. All right, we're going to bring Speaking of
bringing back 2016 2017 memes. Okay, we we got to return to Monkey
or something. It's like it's over. We we we've decid we've actually
proven categorically we can't handle the technology, can't handle
social media, can't handle the internet, can't handle any of
this stuff. We just have to we have to slowly like depopulate.
Go back to living, you know, in harmony with the earth. All right,
it's over. Can I at least still have an iPad? No, you cannot.
No, you cannot.
No, you cannot. We're going to get AI to the point where it can
create compelling media for us. All right. Where people can tell
a story and it can help make that that movie real. So, we could
still have like movies and TV and stuff, but then that's the
only technology we get. All right, that's it. That's it. Or something.
I don't know. I haven't really thought about it yet. >> I
mean, >> no one else can make entertainment. >> No,
get a cabal of people in tiny hats who will consult the AI and
they'll make all of our movies. Okay,
that's the only way. That was where when the world was best.
Okay. >> Every time these people say there are only two
genders, I always hear H's voice in my head singing there are
only two holes. Oh. Oh. And it has nothing to do with genders,
but it's just so good. >> You missed you the cadence. There
are only two holes. Oh,
there are only two holes.
Yeah, that's sorry. You got to
got to get the cadence right. Okay. Oh, this is >> a requirement.
All right,
back to this. Dude, this guy is so schizophrenic. He's gone through
He's gone through leftists,
went on to women, now he's on to trans people. He's going to
hit all the talking points. All right. >> Jesus.
Well, now that I'm cosplaying Hot Miku, I'm going to sue you
if you don't legally refer to me as hot Miku. Sorry,
>> Sorry, Steve.
That's not how the world works.
Jesus.
>> Railing against cancel culture while participating in
cancel culture, right? Railing against cancel culture while trying
to get this on deplatformed. Let's go. There are people who are
fired for saying they're only two genders.
>> And it's embarrassing how long people have lived under
this underneath this oppressive boot. Dude, I remember 2019 through
2024. Holy.
If you didn't appeal yourself to the [__] extremist
left-wingers, you didn't have a career.
I remember this one time. >> I remember 2024. That's like
9 months ago. Did he just say that? >> How long people
have lived under this underneath this oppressive boot? Dude,
I remember 2019 through 2024. >> Oh, 2019 through 2024.
Okay. Through
>> I had to pretend that I tolerated these >> [__]
If you didn't appeal yourself to the [__] extremist
left-wingers, you didn't have a career.
I remember this one time
I had this girl, she came into my chat and she was telling me
about how she's been gas lit by her boyfriend and I heard her
out and I said, "You know what drives me crazy? Not referring
to you by the way, when people misuse those words gaslighting
because I don't really think people know what that word actually
means." because I was on a tangent about words that people use
incorrectly and because this person's feelings was so hurt because
they thought I was referring to their situation. I got like 80,000
hate comments
because feelings
ruled the world over logic and facts. What the are we doing?
Do you really want to live your life according to your woman's
period? You know how much dumb [__] women
I'm not actually listening to what he's saying so much. Okay.
I I'm not listening to what he's saying so much. But I'm just
in my head like can you just steal ideas? Is it like is life
is history just really like actually a circle? Time's a flat
circle. Okay. If we're going to do the True Detective thing,
can you just take things from like six years ago that were popular
and start saying them again and eventually you'll like build
a huge following and and it's fine. It's like Charlie Kirk just
totally aped everything Steven Crowder and Ben Shapiro did. And
is Teone just going to do that like now? He's just like, "Oh,
I'll just take their whole thing and we'll just do it again.
We'll run it back."
That's all that that's all that's happening. There's like nothing
new. There's no good ideas here. It's just like, "Oh, I think
Ben Shapiro was really cool in 2013, 2014. Let's go."
I think I thought Andrew Tate was really awesome that summer
of 2022.
You actually asking that question? Well, I'm just like I think
most people who make something, they like want to talk about
issues they find important. They don't want to just like take
some other people's and only like copy them >> and facts.
What the are we doing? Do you really want to live your life according
to your woman's period? You know how much dumb [__]
women say when they're bleeding out of their vagina? A lot. And
that's why rooting yourself in reality and saying, "Well, babe,
I understand that you're upset, but that simply didn't happen
and I'm not going to apologize for some >> Did he just
fight with his girlfriend? Is this entire video just like he
took a fight with his girlfriend and he was like, I just realized
how he can save the human race." He had an argument. He's pivoted
that into like, "Guys, I just figured it all out. I figured everything,
guys, I got it." Okay, I got >> That didn't happen. It's
comical. We are living in a world where younger children
are very active on social media where they're very reactive.
You have the slow logical part of your brain and you have the
fast reaction emotional part of your brain. And we live in a
fast world where big outrageous reactions get way more clicks
than the the article that's posted 3 days later with what actually
had happened. And that is where everything is going to the wayside
because there's so misinformation is a breeding ground right
now. It's insane.
>> That doesn't make any sense. Misinformation can't be
a breeding ground. That's not that's not a thing that makes any
sense. You're literally just ranting.
Literally, the only format of content you do is ranting about
what you feel in any given moment. >> How many lies get
away with the public? It's insane how many content creators have
allegations that simply just don't
>> Oh, right. He's uh not a Guys, guys, misinformation
is a breeding ground.
And it's possible that based on that breeding ground, you may
think I have done some a little bit of but I did not. And and
it's all lies. >> I mean, I I want to make this clear,
guys, and I I want you to to hear about this.
Some girl got sad one time and lied about a creator because he
broke up with him, and now his career is over because one person
lied.
Because people hear that lie and they run with it. So, >> who
did this happen to that didn't just cancel themselves? Dude,
I watched Dude, I watched Rich Campbell. Rich Campbell was funny
enough to just do this whole to to continue streaming through
his allegations. He just decided not to. He had a lot of money.
He just wanted to take a break. Dude, Rich Campbell could have
done any amount. He could have just done any content he wanted.
He is funny. He's very entertaining. He would have been fine.
That's like the only person he could possibly be referring to.
other people like either actually did the thing or like they
just are fine. Like some people will say there's allegations,
but like Jesus
quick before they listen to anything. It is. By the way, there's
this one really ugly political I can't tell if you're a guy or
a girl. I really got no idea. I don't even know what your name
is, but you react to every single one of my videos. So, can you
just say like, are you a boy or a girl? I really can't tell.
It's it's this one like is a man. one ugly trogodite. Sorry,
this Hey buddies, he's eating rocks. There's this one really
ugly like troglodite like hobgoblin. You look like kind of Asian
and you all >> Oh, he's definitely he's actually literally
talking about food shops. He's actually literally talking about
food shops, which by the way just shows how hardcore he namees
himself all the time.
>> always react to my videos and I always look at this
and I'm like, what the [__] is that? Can you just
clarify what the you are? Cuz you're so I can't even tell. And
that's coming from me. But I'm sure everybody here knows I'm
a white male, an ogre at that point.
>> that shaves is >> we live in a world where the
youth is currently ruling and they don't have the pattern recognition
that the older folks have. They don't understand the destruction
and the despair and the doom and the downfall of our nation that
they are going to bring
when they celebrate what they celebrate when they act what they
do because they have no knowledge. They have no wisdom. They
have no life experience. And they're the type of people who think
that >> No, no, no. He has the pattern recognition. It's
how he got the pattern recognition together to show how those
games were breaking. Guys, is bad. That's he he showed his pattern
recognition because when they introduce a global passive to some
character in a gotacha game, he went, "This game sucks now and
I'm leaving because I know how this goes." And then he basically
tells us that the game got worse, but we have no idea whether
or not it got worse.
That's that's his pattern recognition. Okay, that's his version
of the socks. >> Positively reinforcing your friend when
they're the one who up just because they're sad was the right
thing to do. No, the right thing to do when your friends up is
to hold them accountable. That way they don't make that issue
again. You are not a good friend because you reinforce someone
because they're sad. And if you can't tell someone the truth,
you're a horribleing friend. And that is the reality.
You are not good because you get to tell everybody do whatever
you want. No, you're horrible. This leads to enabling psychotic
behaviors. And I'm sorry, anybody who says yes, do whatever the
you want to do and you're enabling their mental illness. If you
go up to a schizophrenic and say, "Yes, listen to the voices."
Are you a good person? No. Absolutely not. There's a lot of mental
illnesses on this earth that you clearly tell people to not listen
to. But there's one that people really say, "Yeah, listen to
those voices." And we all know which one I'm talking about.
>> Wait, do we I mean, I assume he's talking about trans
people, but I'm not totally sure. >> You're not a good
person if you do that. You're just not. You're not. You need
to understand that some people need help. And when you're the
person who says, "Yeah, do whatever you want. Live the W life
the way you want to live it." I'm sorry. When you're enabling
Becky to suck her 47 that week, you're not a good friend. You're
just a You're not You're not When you tell everybody >> I
No, he's not just talking about women who make accusations. I
don't think so. I think I think he was talking about I actually
think he was talking about trans people and now he's talking
about this, bro. This is the guy, dude. He was just dating a
woman. He literally cheated on his wife or or or dumped his wife
to start dating an Only Fans girl. >> Yes. Yes. Yes. Queen,
you do you. Everybody else is wrong except for you. I'm sorry.
You grow the most in your failures. And a lot of my closest friends
are always there to make sure they know when I up. Just like
when I messaged Shinya and he said, "Hey man, you really need
to grow that beard back." And I said, "Yeah, I think you do."
Oh, Jesus Christ. We're still here, huh? I bet people are like,
"I couldn't even get through this video, bro. He didn't have
his [__] beard."
The longer you live, the more that you will see the same thing.
And you should proceed with caution when you do see the way that
patterns line up. And guys, I'm sorry.
We are at a point where we have ignored pattern recognition so
long that Charlie Kirk died, people celebrated his death, and
they're now shocked why they're losing their jobs.
And they're saying, "Well, the >> Wait, I thought some
people lost their jobs just because they said they're two genders.
How are people losing their jobs now?" >> Right. So, against
cancel culture, but now you're canceling us over this. I'm >> I
was going to explain it. >> Making someone lose their job
because they said because they said fat because they said that
men can't give birth
is a lot different than, "Oh, yes, this guy died. Quick, guys,
more like him. Then we'll finally win. That's
>> Uh, one, nobody's actually mad about people who are
calling for extra violence having like consequences for that.
Two, that's not where it's stopping. It's going on to people
who literally just show indifference. It's going on to people
who literally just won't suck Charlie Kirk off in his death.
Okay? Literally, the bar is suck Charlie Kirk's suck Charlie
Kirk's rigamortis stiff dick or I will cancel you right now.
do it.
Yeah, that's obviously that's okay. No, that's not where the
bar should be and that's where the bar is. You want to say, "Oh,
somebody's calling for violence. We're going to we're going to
deplatform them." Okay, maybe. Okay. Okay. Major Dr. Gastly,
shut up, nerd.
>> Yes. Telling people to go
people because you have a difference of opinion is psychotic.
There's a lot more that I could say.
psychotic. Um, literally I would say there are a lot of things
that are psychotic in terms of speech, free speech that should
be protected. The entire point of speech being protected is that
there's going to be speech you disagree with. Speech you think
is reprehensible and that speech should be protected. That's
the entire purpose of the first amendment is to protect speech
that you find objectionable.
You can't just say, "Oh, well, this is really objectionable though,
but this I really don't like this. I like really really don't
like this. And have you thought about how it's different? Cuz
I don't just really really don't like it. I actually really really
really really really don't like it. Like I did four reallyies
and you only did two reallyies and I like really really really
really really really
don't like it. >> It's like no it doesn't matter how many
times you say you really don't like it. >> Yeah, it doesn't.
No, no, you're not sold. It doesn't matter how many times you
say that. >> I get it. >> I you don't get that worse.
>> No, no,
>> No. But I think you guys understand
>> where I'm going at with this and I think you guys get
the message. So I'll cut the rambling here.
But your mental illness, your ignorance is not our
Change is coming and change is coming
And I think it's for the best because God knows we need it. Bye-bye,
guys.
>> That's where you're wrong. Everyone's mental illness
is everyone's problem.
That's why you even posted that tweet. You're claiming that you
were pushed over the edge and whatever mental illness you have,
it's about to be all of our problems, right?
>> we have no idea what we just created. >> Yeah,
maybe that's what he's talking about. Okay. He's actually he's
actually been infected. Okay. What happened to the black guy,
the Ukrainian woman? All right. That's happened to Teeone. He's
he doesn't understand. Okay. Or sorry, we don't understand. He's
not even responsible for his actions anymore, guys. The government
is making him do [__] All right. The government's
making him warn people first
and then he's going to go out and he's going to do some crazy
[__] He's losing it. Also,
uh where
it's Oh, I was going to pivot into something and then I lost
it. My brain just went blank. Oh no.